legal experts out in the community  tonight reminding tenants that they have  rights if they are being evicted  protections for renters expired last  summer so landlords can now legally  evict anyone who is in paying rent  tonight nevada legal services met with  families at risk near downtown to share  some ways they can buy some extra time  at the end of the day most of these  families will become displaced  unfortunately but at best we can try to  extend it and get a little bit more time  for families so that they can search and  find another place to live  there are several different scenarios  where a family could get extensions on  an eviction nevada legal services say it  is best to reach out directly for  specific advice